everyone has an opinion on cheats and
whether or not they should be used box
[Music]
but if you're the type of person who
wants to mess around inside the guts of
the game and fall out for a secret room
might be for you I'm Kate and this is
your GameSpot news update the secret
room inside of Bethesda's
post-apocalyptic RPG fallout 4 has been
discovered the room accessible in the
game's PC version
apparently features every item in the
game including all weapons armor items
and more youtube-channel Tyranno con has
an overview of what you'll find you can
get into the fallout 4 secret room by
entering the tilde and then Co CQ a
smoke in the games console commands
which is the same command ID they used
in Fallout 3 New Vegas and Skyrim to
escape the room again just type COC
followed by the name of the location and
ext it's not really a cheat though it's
a developer testing room a similar room
was also found in Skyrim the most recent
game before fallout 4 developed by
Bethesda Game Studios have you been
using console commands what are your
thoughts on using exploits like these
let us know in the comments or find me
on Twitter and how not to draw I'm Kate
and thanks for watching
[Music]